en el vídeo anterior nombramos a esta
molécula usando los nombres comunes de
los grupos isobutilo que se encontraban
acá abajo pero pensé que sería divertido
hacerlo también con la nomenclatura
sistemática verdad entonces lo único que
tenemos que cambiar es el nombre de
estos grupos hizo wood y lo cual sería
entonces el nombre digamos sistemático
para esto si realmente nos tenemos que
fijar en el carbono que se une a la
cadena principal o al ciclo principal en
este caso y encontramos la cadena más
larga que en este caso sería esta de
aquí que estamos marcando con rojo
verdad esta sería la cadena más larga y
que consta de tres átomos de carbono eso
nos da algo del tipo propio y verdad
propia porque son tres átomos de carbono
el porque es un grupo alquiló y
finalmente podemos notar que tenemos un
un átomo de carbono uniéndose a el
segundo verdad es decir te tendremos en
realidad un grupo metilo unido al
segundo
átomo de carbono de esta de esta cadena
o esta sub cadena o suba estructura que
encontramos verdad entonces esto nos
dice que es un 2 metil propia verdad 2
porque está unido en el segundo carbono
metil porque justo lo que se une es un
grupo metilo y propio porque nuestra
estructura principal es un grupo propio
y lo verdad y esto es justamente lo que
tenemos que cambiar en lugar de
isobutilo y tenemos dos verdad tenemos
dos uno que está en el carbono 5 y otro
que está en el carbono 7 ahora déjenme
copiar justamente lo que teníamos hasta
aquí verdad hasta este momento hasta
esta parte tenemos exactamente igual
verdad entonces simplemente copiamos y
pegamos esa parte lo único que lo único
que cambia es justamente esta parte del
isobutilo verdad entonces en este caso
vamos a tener en el carbono 5 y en el 7
en el carbono
5 perdón es verdad en el carbono 5 y 7
vamos a tener dos de estos y para
ponerlo para poner que son 2 ponemos un
bis porque en la nomenclatura
sistemática utilizamos bis verdad y
ahora qué es lo que vamos a poner
justamente este este nombre que tenemos
aquí copiamos y pegamos y ahí lo tienen
verdad entonces el nombre completo sería
1/4 de ciclo útil 2 ciclo propio 57 bis
2 metil propio y terminamos con ciclo
ciclo octano que es el nombre de nuestra
estructura principal nuevamente bis se
utiliza para decir que hay 2 y 2 metil
propio quiere decir que en un grupo
propio en el segundo carbono de ese
tenemos un grupo metilo entonces ahí lo
tienen tenemos también el nombre
sistemático para esta molécula